حسنًا أندرسون هذا
اقتراح استثنائي من إسرائيل والذي
تعهد بالطبع بتدمير حماس بالكامل أه ما
أخبرني به
مسؤولان منفصلان أه على علم
بالمناقشات الجارية حول
وقف إطلاق نار أوسع والذي سيشهد أه
إطلاق سراح الرهائن الإسرائيليين  حسنًا، هو أن إسرائيل
اقترحت أن يغادر كبار قادة
حماس قطاع غزة الآن،
وسيكون من غير المعقول التفكير في
أن إسرائيل ستسمح بشكل أساسي
لمنسقي فرقة "مهندسو
7 أكتوبر"، الهجوم الأكثر دموية في
تاريخ إسرائيل، أه ببساطة يبتعدون أه أنا'
وأخبرت أن هذا أمر
أثاره رئيس
المخابرات الإسرائيلية ديفيد بارنيا عندما التقى
بنظيره الأمريكي بيل بيرنز
مدير وكالة المخابرات المركزية وكذلك رئيس
الوزراء القطري الشهر الماضي وقد
أثير مرة أخرى أه عندما وزير الخارجية
أنتوني  بلينكين كان في الدوحة في وقت سابق من هذا
الشهر أه هذا شيء أه من
شبه المؤكد أنه لن يحدث أه
ولكن في نفس الوقت أندرسون إنه
يسلط الضوء حقًا على حقيقة أن إسرائيل
حققت أه تقدمات قليلة نسبيًا عندما
يتعلق الأمر بتفكيك وتدمير
حماس  لدينا
القيادة العليا لحماس أه التي لا تزال على
قيد الحياة ويعتقد أنها موجودة في تلك
الأنفاق أه لديك حوالي 70% من
قوة حماس المقاتلة أه
بتقدير إسرائيل الخاص لا تزال أه في
ساحة المعركة الآن بالطبع هذا يمكن أن
يفيد إسرائيل أيضًا إذا  هؤلاء
قادة حماس لو خرجوا سيضعف أه
حماس في قطاع غزة سينزع
قيادتهم وسيسمح
أه إسرائيل باستهداف قادة حماس
أينما ذهبوا وإسرائيل قالت
مرارا إنهم ينوون أه التجول
حول العالم أه  والقتل يقتل
قادة حماس بسبب 7 أكتوبر.
أندرسون هل هناك إحساس بمدى احتمالية
قبول حماس لتلك
الشروط بشكل جيد من
المسؤولين الأمريكيين والدوليين الذين تحدثت معهم، من
المستبعد للغاية أن يقولوا أه
الوزير بلينكين قد أخبره القطري  رئيس الوزراء
أن شيئًا كهذا
لن يحدث أبدًا القادة الذين
كانوا يتحدثون عن أندرسون هم يحيى
سنير وهو رئيس حماس في غزة
وهناك محمد ديف يمكنك رؤيته هناك
على الشاشة أيضًا وهو رئيس أه
الجناح العسكري
مروان عيسى، نائب ديف، هؤلاء الرجال
مؤمنون حقيقيون، متعصبون دينيون،
أيديولوجيون، لذا
يعتقد المسؤولون الذين أتحدث معهم أنهم يريدون
الموت بشكل أساسي وهم يقاتلون ضد
عدوهم اللدود، هناك موقف واحد قام به
آرون ديفيد ميلر والمحللون أنت وأنا
معًا  أعلم جيدًا أه أن السيد
يمكن أن
لو أه إسرائيل وافقت على إطلاق سراح جميع
الأسرى الفلسطينيين بعض من أه أه
وأشد السجناء فتكًا في
السجون الإسرائيلية ثم أه ميلر قال لي
سنير ربما تفكر في ذلك ولكن هذا هو أن هذا
الاحتمال بعيد  لقد
رفض نتنياهو بشكل أساسي
بالأمس فقط أندرسون مدى
الضغط الذي يمارس على نتنياهو
لإيجاد حل، قدر غير عادي
من الضغط وهو يتزايد في
اليوم الذي كنت فيه في إسرائيل الشهر الماضي فقط
وأتحدث مع عائلات الرهائن الذين
يحتجون جميعًا  في الوقت الذي
يقولون فيه بشكل أساسي لنتنياهو عليك
أن تفعل كل ما بوسعك أه لإعادتهم إلى
الوطن، لذلك هذا شيء هذا
ضغط يتزايد فقط في اليوم
أه نتنياهو يعرف أن عليه فعل
شيء ما ولكن في نفس الوقت أندرسون
هو  وتعهد بأن هذه الحرب ستستمر
لعدة أشهر قادمة